and welcome back to the readers podcast
in the dunya the three muslims podcast
today we're going to be talking about a
really relevant issue something that has
been going on since the internet
honestly has been here was something we
call fit in the warriors
and now fired why don't you describe to
us what these fitnah warriors do and who
they are
habibi
bro before i answer your question i got
a question for you bro are we really the
the realest podcast in the dhonia or are
we the self-proclaimed realist podcast
and dunya
i don't think we have any competitors
honestly i think we are
there we go there we go i like that bro
uh hope you guys are doing well both of
you and uh to all of our lovely brothers
and sisters that tuned in
fitna warriors bro
how do i describe a fitnah warrior
somebody that wakes up with the sole
purpose of going on youtube or going on
the internet and just spreading fitnah
now anha i'm asking reaver this question
what does the word fitna
it's
mean
you're basically causing issues for no
reason right
i like that i like that
is that what it is
yeah i believe fitna just means like a
trial or test or tribulation
or just like basically like lip but just
unnecessary things to deal with at least
in this case but fitna just means trial
or tribulation so
these people
and you know there's also another term
keyboard warriors you know what i mean
so these are the type of people that you
know when let's i'll give an example
right mohammed hijab makes a uyghur
speech um shirtless he has that you know
that little pouch covering his aura and
i'm not here to say if that's covering
your order or not that's a different
issue but the people that that they tune
in and they're doing the least but they
got the most to say about muhammad hijab
saying why did you say this why did you
do this
yet bro what are you doing and as ana
said if you could do better than do
better you know what i mean
got a new member here into clickbait
salaam alaikum
and welcome to the side bro the dark
side
no
do you guys have any experience with
this bro whatsoever
of course i think everyone has
experience with it
yeah any muslim internet that posts
anything to be honest
let me let me rephrase my question
um what i meant to say was do you guys
have any experience
being a victim warrior
oh like actually being that yeah yeah
bro yeah
maybe a keyboard warrior like back when
i was a little kid
you were calling duty in call of duty
but like it was when i was little little
like
i don't know i can't everybody
no honestly there's there's not a time i
can remember
when i like what other people's posts
and became like a like a fitnah warrior
keyboard warrior like when i saw
something that was like that was a
fitness in and of itself i would comment
on it so in that sense you know i fought
against the fit now maybe i'm fitting a
warrior in that sense but not in the way
that we're talking about
okay okay all right now tell me this bro
um
and he's the thing when gabriel was
telling us about you know dealing with
fitnah warriors and all this online he
was he was saying one thing that
sometimes you just can't you know let
things get to you so a lot of people
what they do is they don't read any
comments they don't read any of the the
hate
now i personally see
little
i guess
absolute value in that because if you're
saying i'm not going to read anything
how are you gonna read you know even the
good comments you know what i mean
but at the same time if you go in saying
okay i wanna at least read the good
you're not gonna know when a fitnah
warrior is gonna enter the chat bro you
really don't because they're everywhere
so for you two how do you guys navigate
today's social
media and online space knowing that
every now and then you might just see
people that that really try to push you
and really try to just bring out the
worst in you
you're saying it's someone who has like
a channel like
an influencer or are you talking about
like just a random
not as influencers bro because i i allah
knows bro the fitness warriors we got
now nowhere near before we had a
platform
i just look for genuine questions
you know a long time ago
when i used to watch uh elliott hoes
shout out to him
may uh i love blessing with islam
uh
he used to say
that you shouldn't get caught up in like
the
the hype
nor the um
you know like
the dirt like if they're throwing dirt
on your name
like if they're
talking good about you they're giving
you praise or if they're giving you like
negative feedback and putting you down
you don't pay attention to that because
at the end of the day like you're not
doing it for that
you're just doing it to like get
something across
right
and i've just learned like look look for
the genuine questions and then halas
like if someone wants to leave a
positive comment may allah bless them
may allah reward them and raise them in
rank for that
but
if i'm trying to respond back to every
single comment then inevitably i'm gonna
start seeing the negative comments and
the negative comments don't do anything
for you
yeah
that's true what i mean what about you
bro
um to be honest the only place where i i
read
comments in their majorities nowadays is
tick tock and i don't post that much on
tick tock um but what what i do when i
do read the comments and um
and again that is just mainly on tick
tock which is the most toxic place ever
um is i
every time i say something that i think
is a negative comment or disagreeing
with whatever i said or whatever it is i
just take a critical look at it and and
if i honestly believe that this has no
intellectual value then i leave it
because it could be the case that the
person is saying something in a rude way
or in a mean way in a degrading way that
has some truth to it and i don't think
anyone should you know react to anything
in that way
but if there's good and if there's some
kind of truth in it then like i'm
willing to take a step back and see what
i said and and be critical of myself so
i'll take a critical look at what they
said
and uh most of the time i'll come to the
conclusion that they're just being an
idiot they have no idea what to talk
about and then me knowing that they have
no idea what they're talking about it
just gives me that that push to
completely dismiss it or maybe even
delete it depending on what it says
i agree bro
what actually gets you to be influenced
if someone wants you to let's say change
for the better
like what do you guys actually respond
to both of you like if someone comes
into it like with ego or with hate you
know it's just the way they word things
the way they phrase things it's almost
like off-putting and you don't even want
to like take it into account or if
someone's kind of like sincere and
gentle and and proper not a fit nowhere
you know what i mean
yeah like i said in many previous videos
you got to know when to be hard and when
to be solved
yeah
yeah
um
i think that you know you should always
be sincere and kind uh especially when
you're giving the sale when you're
giving advice because that was another
process he didn't go around yelling at
people to to to do certain things
uh he would tell them kindly so
that's and also knowledge
if the person quotes me quran especially
if it's something new i don't know about
then that will definitely change my
heart inshaallah but when they come to
me because you can have people that say
things the nicest way that they're
saying nonsense like i've had people
come to me in the nicest way even like
people close to me in the nicest way and
they say you know just don't talk about
this issue don't talk about this tissue
i want what's best for you don't talk
about this xyz and i'm like it's a part
of islam you want me to go to hell
i have to talk about it
so
knowledge and kindness
that's true
yeah it's just it's funny man when i i
do see that stuff because like obviously
like i said i look for genuine questions
right
whether it be on the ttm channel whether
it be on uh my own channel
but like sometimes i'll be like looking
and i'll just see like the most
randomness hate comments
whereas like this person is clearly
muslim
but they're leaving just such hate and
like when i see something like that it
shows me number one like where they are
internally
but then number two like it's just sad
that someone feels like
they have the ability to say something
like this when they probably wouldn't
say something like this in person and if
they did they would be scrutinized by
every other person around them
you know so like this whole fitness
warrior thing like it just
it comes from an emotional place with no
grounding
and if it was done in person it would
not be accepted
it would not be accepted i think it
wouldn't be accepted
yeah a lot of the time it wouldn't even
be said it wouldn't be satisfying
thanks for joining us bro every week
yeah i agree both of you uh what you
said so there's no grounding and also it
wouldn't be accepted so
what do you think their their ideology
stems from bro do you guys think it's
like insecurity or like these people
genuinely wake up like how do i spread
fitna every single day how do i like
just ruin people's moods like where do
you think they're coming from
i think it's genuine security
go ahead bro
i was just gonna say i don't think it's
a goal they have like oh i wanna wake up
and
and if they do man that's the well
that's some hefty punishment they're
gonna have to face um i do think it's a
part of their prayers when you say
punishment bro you mean by allah yeah by
allah so we're making it clear that
allah can definitely question them on
why they do this why they they make the
muslims lives and just people's lives in
general harder for no reason
yeah of course allah is going to
question every little thing our action
and our attention people don't know this
people like
people don't understand that both the
action this is a side note the both the
action and the intention need to be
correct if you have good action bad
intention it doesn't count
if you have um bad action good intention
it doesn't count
so an example of a good action bad
intention would be like let me i don't
know build a masjid but let me do it for
clout kind of like that right or let me
help you like a lot of homeless people
but let me my main intention is how i
can make like ad revenue through it you
know what i mean i stuck for a lot but
not actually helping but what would be
something with like
good uh intent sorry yeah good intention
bad action
yeah good intention bad action would be
like
um
robbing a bank to give to the the poor
you know what i mean
okay
yeah or like even even if you even if
you see something in a video that you
think is wrong like talking about
keyboard warriors or whatever
if you see something that you think is
wrong and then you go and the comments
start cussing them out you're an
embarrassment to islam you they say that
you might have the good intention of
correcting whatever they're doing but
that's the worst action you can you can
take because if anything that's going to
push them further down the route that
they're they're going in so i don't
think these people wake up like oh let
me do this that and if they do again i'm
just you know going to deal with them in
allah but i do think it's a part of
their character you know we have this
huge like one cancel culture and we have
this huge
just very critical culture it's like
everyone's uh everyone's like a
uh muhaddith like uh
critic nowadays you know how the
muhammad their job is to criticize
narrators and all that
so the muhaddith the people like the
people who say certain things are
like certain hadith are authentic or
unauthentic their job is to criticize
people and there's a certain science
where like the the people would go
around following narrators and criticize
them
and they they were rough in character
because they had to be that was their
job that was their life for us now and
it's been a long night everyone's
these days this person's uh hypocrite
this person is a liar this person the
kadab and like all the stuffs
welcome to the games
it's funny bro
again like it just it doesn't make sense
you know like i've had people on my
channel
where
the muslim like i said they're clearly
muslim but then they're like oh this
guy's a fake muslim like
as a real muslim like you don't have
tattoos i'm like
allah knows this
so it is not just insecurity i think
it's also comes from a place of a lack
of understanding
lack of knowledge
you know
so it's like they might like that
knowledge
but then it's like that ignorance is
causing them to have a good intent with
a bad action
yeah yeah
and at that point it's like
they can't claim the ignorance card they
can't claim a i didn't know allah is
gonna you know forgive me because allah
says
to seek knowledge allah says to reap
like
we're told to keep seeking knowledge
so now if they don't have the knowledge
over it like and that's on them they
chose not to seek knowledge bro uh so
i'm gonna ask you a two-part question
alright the first question is gonna be a
physics question bro uh if we got 50
viewers right now in the live stream how
many likes should we have
300. there we go that like that totally
makes sense bro so why do we not have
300 likes come on guys get the likes up
smash the like button number two um
what do you think is more important bro
more people asking you at least i'm
assuming now someone comes up to you
pulls up on you run up on you and
they're like yo a real muslim doesn't
have tattoos you're a fake muslim suck
for allah if someone says that i'm
assuming you really don't care too much
today right
but what contributed more to that growth
and to you i guess sharpening that sword
or i guess toughening up or at least
thickening your skin in terms of that
one aspect was there more people giving
you that fitnah more of these comments
that kind of showed you that you don't
care or you doing the research and
coming to an understanding that if
you're a reaver and you have tattoos
like you know you're forgiven allah
forgives you so why should it matter
like what's more important to you
it was
three things
okay
always keep the three
bro
but the first one
was first having that knowledge like
understanding the truth not just hearing
whatever something someone's saying and
then accepting that to be the truth
so finding the source for myself
number two
was actually receiving these negative
comments from people online because
it i guess it desensitized me
and then number three was um
kind of
proving
to myself like going out to masjids and
like being around other muslims who i
knew
that deep down like in their head they
would probably look at me like stop from
allah
because i got the tattoos
and then having like multiple of the
brothers even come up to me like oh
brother like i'll pay for your tattoo
removal i was like brother i got a lot
of tattoos are you gonna be paying over
a hundred and something k
like it's better if you you spend that
money elsewhere like there's better
forms of charity than to try to pay for
someone to have their tattoos removed
when
allah has already forgiven them for
their tattoos and allah accepts them for
their tattoos it's you
that don't accept them for their tattoos
because you think that well you know you
know that tattoos are haram
but you're failing to see
the entire picture you're failing to see
that they're a revert that they've
already been forgiven
you see what i'm saying
so it's like going through those three
things that's what you know kind of
allah yeah cemented it and jasim or
haseem salaam alaikum bro if you would
be so kind enough to please comment down
below since you remember um how to
pronounce your name bro like
you know how like when you when you
google like a dictionary definition you
see like
the word how it's spelled and then you
see like how it's pronounced
so if you would be so kind bro because i
don't want to keep you know you're
youtube member bro you're supporting us
you're supporting the fam i don't want
to keep uh mispronouncing your name i'm
sure the brothers wouldn't want to do
that either
yeah
you're going with justine
[Music]
would you would you also call it
jalapeno or
what's going on bro
i don't know exactly bro
um
okay i see what you mean now
you're not out here
uncovering your tats
and like you know your whole body of
tattoos every single video you're out
here like hey guys look at my tattoos
this tattoo means like you're not out
here in people's faces you get what i
mean
but at the same time
like if someone just sees a little
little ink in your sleeve and they get
bothered by that you know like that
shows more about them than you at the
end of the day especially when you're
here talking about something else and
you combine that with the fact that no
one's forcing them to watch us bro
like no one's forcing anyone to watch
anyone on youtube
isn't that right
yeah and on top of that people are
supposed to assume the best
like they're supposed to they're
supposed to assume maybe the brother's a
river and he got them beforehand you
know they're not supposed to assume that
you know he was a river he became muslim
then got the tattoos after he knew it
was wrong
thank you
of course
of course um
just to kind of answer the question i
know it was for angel but for myself in
one way
for becoming a youtube member
subhanallah bro honestly
i genuinely don't care what people say
like i like alhamdulillah generally at
this point just don't care what people
say anymore um this is because back when
i was getting here on tik tok you know
all that stuff
i had people
that absolutely seemed to love me to
love my page even bro even people that
wanted to marry me at one point
literally people want to marry me at one
point
who would support me
like crazy in the beginning as soon as
that happened they were in my comments
making dua against me making dua allah
never gives
and it's like
i swear to god bro
a few months after the fact they're back
in my lives
talking like nothing happened they're
back commenting my videos just acting
like they were making dua against me
like five seconds ago
i see what you're doing
well i'll protect this man
i mean bro i mean bro so how do you
pronounce it just yeah i don't want to
say it because i'm probably gonna say it
wrong it's either jasim or jason or
something like that yeah jason or
justine
yeah
all right so
roswell seven thank you for speaking
about the tattoo issue yeah
alhamdulillah
for being aware that it's an issue to be
spoken of right it's it's it's one of
many issues that a lot of rivers face
today you know what i mean and to me to
me again just to me we did a reaction
video brother jeffrey lang who uh he was
basically saying that about 97 of the
quran is not rules and regulations halal
and haram only three percent is i'm not
saying that's not important but what i'm
saying is if you have a new reverb
like we gotta establish tauhid first bro
and and and of course they already
they're already aware of that if they're
a reaver but
we gotta push that more forward we gotta
we gotta talk about you know salah
yeah okay if they're not necessarily
doing something that we should be doing
just yet but it's not in one of the the
five core pillars of islam like
something like
the most important in the list then
you're out here giving them the most
hate for that and subhanallah a lot of
people leave islam for that bro
and i don't think that's that's going
anywhere if you really think about it
like
how rami how would you say we balance
this this this scale the one side where
we kind of want to you know not like
authentically unapologetically show
islam but then the other side where it's
kind of like we can't do too much too
quick
yeah so i mean just it depends on the
person you have to look at them you have
to not over burden them if you find that
they're they learn how to pray in a day
you know that person is moving
relatively quick masha allah you can you
know add more over time and once they
establish their prayer and everything
not just it's jasmine
bless you
uh jason for for joining us allah
before i get to the actually i like this
comment i want to read it i think ali
alayhi salam said something along the
lines of give your muslim brother 100
excuses before you think worst of him
yeah yeah you find this all over
uh islamic literature as well from
different places
who said that if you see alcohol on your
brother's beard assume that someone
spilled it on him or he spilled it not
that he was drinking alcohol
yeah yeah
so um
you have to balance it based on the
person you have to look at like you said
what's the fundamentals okay the five
pillars of islam the six pillars of iman
um and these are things that they need
to believe in when they before they even
become muslim to be honest so make sure
those things are established and that
they believe in them that they're doing
their you know for it that they know
what the farah it is that the fart is um
and then start getting into
uh deeper like you know who was allah
get them to read the quran they get to
learn about the prophet
and then over time you can introduce
them to
the rulings
um to the different madahi whatever you
want or just start teaching them
whatever method you follow since you're
technically their teacher at that point
and um just make sure it's it's it's
nice and slow of a build but it has to
be
uh within the person's intention they
have to be willing they have to be
capable and you have to make sure that
you tell them what islam is that islam
is submission to allah it's not just
praying and fasting it is i'm gonna i'm
probably gonna give up things later in
my life
when i realize that certain things are
haram i'm gonna change my life and
change your life for the better that's
the whole point but they have to have to
understand that i think from the
beginning is important
good answer bro i know what about you
i kind of blinked out okay honestly i'll
give you an example my guy you have a
cousin or a friend or a sibling or just
someone that
let's say they're new into islam how do
you balance the whole i need to show
them authentic unapologetic true real
islam
with no reformed oh you could still be
muslim and be xyz you guys assume once
xyz um so how do you balance that but
also okay let me not give them too much
where they bite off more than they can
true let me not let me not push them
away further do you know what i
[Music]
uh you get a mean
by little
you just give little by little
like if they already
you talking about someone who's like
accepted islam correct yeah for example
after you reverted what really helped
you
grow uh well for me it was just kind of
looking into things on my own
but for other people to be different
other people like listening to videos
lectures and stuff like that other
people like
um reading into the text
you know um
everyone's different some people like
just speaking to people like friends or
or shake or something like that
but at the end of the day
like whatever way
you're gonna take you know
to actually learn and to
you know further yourself in your team
just to go little by little and allah
even says it
himself he's like you just
it's just a little like
it's better that you do something very
small
for you know
for your deen
for allah just very little every single
day
then to do something very big at once
and then not do something again for like
another week two weeks a month two
months
which that's i feel like that's the
biggest thing where people gotta
understand this is a
marathon not a sprint
you know like you ain't trying to learn
as much as possible
to try to show out
to try to be able to debate and to prove
someone wrong to be able to try to
impress someone now that you're learning
it for yourself
you're learning it so that you
can advance and progress and elevate
yourself
in rank and shut up you remember
inshallah you remember when you you said
you first reverted and you got you were
loaded with emails more people were
writing paragraphs and paragraphs and
here's the thing my guy
yes alhamdulillah they mean well no
one's denying that bro of course we're
going to assume they mean they mean well
but like did it sometimes get
overwhelming for you where you sometimes
you're like okay let me take a step back
sometimes my bro was overwhelming from
the rip from the like just from the
start
and it's like the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said when he was asked
about
um i guess the the new muslim someone
becoming muslim like us please chime in
because i'm gonna butcher this and i
don't know what a hundred percent
but he was like oh first
teach them
uh
he said steps i don't remember the steps
but he started with like
if i remember correctly i think it was
uh the belief
in one god
uh the belief in i think the angels
and then so on and so on like
learning how to pray wasn't even the
first one if i remember correctly please
chime in one of you
remember
we got we got two questions bro before
we quickly go in
uh so first one we got a
member comment this is a very important
topic that i don't think is discussed
enough me a lot of wordy brothers i mean
for your contribution to them
except for us i mean
all right jazakallah for the super chat
may allah continue to bless you brothers
this channel really helped me understand
certain things as a reaver martial
i mean i mean and may we continue to
bring value and benefit you and and
really do at least
not just change their lives but but
continue changing our lives and continue
improving because allah knows that this
channel has helped us
more than you guys think
yeah
yeah
yeah
what's up you were gonna think he's
saying
he doesn't know the hadith okay yeah i
was just i was just saying like it it
vaguely sounds familiar but i can't
remember is there is there i mean
if any if anyone knows it by any means
like throw it in here
elevate
yeah the point the point of where i was
trying to get it is like
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had already mentioned
uh
just to start slow you know you got to
do this in steps you can't just throw
everything on to the person
and like i understand all these people
that reached out to me had good
intentions just like
all the brothers and sisters that reach
out to new muslims
to give them the information they have
good intentions
but again it's all about like the baby
steps
so like
if when i became muslim i think the best
thing for me would have been like
just understanding more
over like what allah is and what the
angels are and just everything that like
the quran is explaining you know i read
the quran by myself but i didn't truly
understand everything a hundred percent
yes it clicked yes
it showed me you know allah showed me
that okay this is this is the answer
this is the way
but as far as like
the realizations and like understanding
that i'm getting now
from reading the quran even further in
depth reading better translations and
speaking to people
that have the knowledge over it
that has uh
that that's further implemented
the uh foundation where it's like you
know what i could have just started with
that first
and then from there
i could have learned how to recite surah
fatiha
and then from there i could have learned
how to recite uh maybe the sunnah
prayers like surah class
uh
what's the other one
yeah so it's like bro like
it's little by little you know little by
little and it's i like to explain it as
like
uh
if you pick up the quran
right you read a few pages at a time
and then you put a bookmark in it
right and then when you come back to
read it
you
basically picking up where you left off
with the bookmark you're not gonna pick
up the quran and try to read it all in
one go
you could
you're going to be reading for a long
time and you're probably not going to
retain what's being you know what you're
reading
but
trying not to do baby steps trying to do
more than you can handle at once it's
the same as trying to read the quran all
in one go sure you can do it but is it
the best thing probably not
hmm
bro like there's people that once they
revert they make a lot of quick changes
but then they also burn out just as
quick right so ana's trying to say that
you know it's better that you do
something consistently and build a
foundation slowly where you know if you
want to look more into that he has a
youtube channel and he made a video
called self-improvement happens in steps
or what i wish i knew about
self-improvement something like that i
knew it was posted in within the last
six months it was a very good video and
i truly personally benefited from that
and he basically says that what i wish i
would have known about self-improvement
is when you want to take something on in
your life for example let me work on my
prayers let me pray five times a day
you're not gonna do it overnight and if
you do more chances than not you're
gonna burn out so it's better that you
okay i'm gonna make sure i play fajr
every single day no matter what then i'm
gonna add in makarov let's say then
aisha then the
sir and once until two salah per day two
pairs per day becomes easy i'm not even
gonna do three then three then four
now we're not saying take baby steps to
the point where you're gonna take
forever let's not let's not cap now all
right deep down you know what's too slow
we're not saying anything like that
we're just saying don't go too
fast and people got to understand
there is no
finish line here
the finish line is reaching jannah
inshallah
right that's the finish line
but for us like in our seeking of
knowledge
there is no finish line where it's like
okay i've reached this point then i'm
good i reach this point and then allah
will accept me into jannah no you you
could be in the very beginning
and allah will accept you into jannah
because allah is the one that is going
to judge between all of us
right so like again there's no finish
line there's no reason to rush take your
time with it even if even if you've
really only learned so little
if you did everything
to the best of your ability if you had
the best intention
like allah knows this
you know allah knows again you don't
want to prolong
for whatever reason because again allah
knows best so if you are prolonging
and it's not legit allah knows
but if
if it's taking a while
and you are just genuinely you're not
trying to prolong it's just genuinely
taking you a while
for everything to sink in with you
allah knows best
you know so again there's no finish line
there's no point that you have to reach
this is for
your experience here in this dunya to
further yourself in your deen
i just want to quickly jump in here and
say that i have to go in about five or
six minutes okay
so no no
right now 44 bro rami's gonna miss the
the q a today but it's fine i got a
quick question bro for me before you uh
before you wrap up your uh your leave
for today um let's say you're a manager
let's say you're like hr you're hiring
or you're recruiting for a company let's
say it's your prized company you care
about it it's your possession you don't
want to just hire anyone from the street
you got two people all right one person
they got 10k in their bank account
another person they got a million in the
bank account
the person that has 10k
i'm gonna use anaheim's example about
you know taking steps and really working
for it the person that has 10k they
started with zero all right they they
truly grinded and they learned
everything about business and finance
and economics and everything a month ago
they had zero and today they have 10k
whereas a person with a million dollars
they started with 10 million they were
born into a rich family and they blew
off 9 million
right they might seem like they're
farther ahead like anh is saying
but allah might love someone early on
but anyway my point is who would you
hire
yeah i'd hire the person that works for
the 10k that they have
you're not just going to judge someone's
bank balance or like for example looking
at two muslims and see oh who looks more
muslim or who looks like they have more
iman or who looks like allah loves it
more which will never know right
yeah 100 100 it's a good example
but this is this is where it's like
it stops one from being arrogant
where it's like okay yeah
you do your prayers yeah you do thicker
yeah you read the quran
yeah you seek more knowledge and and you
seek more understanding
but then let's say there's someone who
who
they don't have as much time for that
you can't look at them and then have
arrogance just a hint of arrogance
thinking that you're better than them
because you do all these things
because the moment you have that hidden
arrogance that strips everything that
you're doing away all the rewards all
the butter color you're getting from
what you're doing is stripped away
because a lot doesn't love arrogance
you know it's that's crazy though
i'm gonna be like that because yeah and
i'm gonna quickly change the the
live chat
thing to uh subscribers for members
uh but either way i'm gonna leave in two
minutes so if you guys really wanna talk
to us and and be a part of the episode
for the live episodes make sure you join
as a youtube member every single friday
inshaallah 11 a.m eastern standard time
but while i do that bro one of you can
uh carry
i think when it comes to reverse just
like to go back on the topic for a
second when it comes to reverse i think
that the only thing they need to not
rush but really
really like aim to get down
are the the foreign
the the what you have to believe to be a
muslim
what you have to do
in terms of your action to be a muslim
the five pillars of islam essentially
and once they're they're at a place
where they're doing everything allah
commands them to do
then it's going to be a long journey of
seeking knowledge and making revisions
in life over time i'm still making
revisions in my life i'm going to be
completely honest i i didn't know that
and this is a good example because i've
been muslim for years bro i've been
practicing for years
i didn't know that
i can't
trim my beard at all i thought like okay
i can i can clean it up because i
remember hearing that one so that you
can clean it up
but i can't talk about it bro we were
just talking about it there's a certain
length that you can keep i don't even
think i have the length i think the
length is off but the length is a
difference of opinion so the most
authentic one is you're not supposed to
cut it at all
yeah that's what me and ramy did
research on there's a video by sheikh
with manufa that i'll send to you that
army sent to me
it was about uh all the rulings related
to trimming and all that but apparently
we're not supposed to cut it at all
touch it at all yeah and actually uh
it's found a lot i think someone who
watches the channel sent it to me so
they sent to me i sent to you you sent
to ano masha allah so what it what if
you do call your b
if you do like ask for ask allah to
forgive you and don't do it again but
like
if you guys go back and watch some
episodes you'll see my beard was a lot
shorter i actually trimmed it at a
certain point in time because i thought
i was allowed to but see this is a
revision that i had to make in my life
that's the point that you find
and you make revisions yeah you're gonna
grow your beard out for the rest of your
life
yes
you're gonna like
i mean i don't think it'll ever reach
like you know down to my chest but i'm
gonna do my best marshall i've been
waiting to say this on looking like a
muslim sifu master that is on a long
journey of building his iman iman imam
bro and preparing for his
while being able to uh
put hands on
but i came across you like six years ago
in my mid teens and now seeing you have
accepted islamic continues to make me
happy every time i get reminded may
allah be with you mashallah
with allah i mean allah is always with
us with everyone may allah
[Music]
very well said
uh we're not gonna give like photos or
anything like that we're just giving
what we have studied from different
scholars but we highly recommend that if
you want islamic
uh legitimate
islamic rulings that you go consult a
scholar with that being said i think
it's time for romney to go because you
got your prior engagement
yes yes my prior engagement
all honestly i'm going to say it now
we're not ending the episode but since
i'm leaving i'm going to say it now
my
buddy writes what is fitnah warrior
and then write three three guys in one
channel
uh
i don't know what to say to that buddy
we said what it was throughout the
entire beginning
alhamdulillah yes bro i just heard back
from him i'm not allowed to say too much
because there's stuff going on but
hamdulillah he's fine
keep him in your doors he's good he
reached out to me uh last week exactly
after i announced it and then i looked
up
yeah he's doing well inshallah he's
going to be back on our channel sometime
soon he's just sorting out some affairs
alhamdulillah
bro i want you to answer this question
it's a really good question
i want to establish my daily prayers but
i'm so scared of turning back to allah
again and i'm falling off again
i don't want to be a hypocrite but i
don't know when i'll ever be ready to
truly commit
allah knows best
as long as you're always sincere and
always making the effort to go back
allah knows best
right like
i can't say
that like oh it's all right for you to
go
start praying doing stuff and then just
stop praying
and then come back and then start
praying again all i'm gonna say is allah
knows best if you're sincere and you're
always making that sincere intent
to get closer to allah to pray to do
everything then
yeah
may allah accept it for me i mean europe
i mean and bro we have we did an episode
yesterday that's gonna air on sunday
with uh we're not gonna name any names
now yeah we're gonna keep it low-key but
he's from the uk we've been wanting to
get him for a while now
and uh some people might know some
people might not know but uh we haven't
adam yet and it was a really good
episode right and he himself
um he was saying that you know sometimes
we all take breaks from studying islam
and coming closer to allah but what he
was saying is is not like break as an
abandoning but it's like sometimes
you're not going as fast as you want to
go but he said it's better
that you're on the right path
and that you're at least going the right
way
instead of going fast
and going between the right way and the
wrong way you know what i mean so you
don't want to just go a long way but
then go the wrong way you want to go the
right way first and foremost and try
your best to go as fast as you can may
allah keep a steadfast but it's not the
most important thing in the world as
long as you're doing what you could do
even if you're not perfect it's not
about being perfect but it's about
taking perfect actions every single day
to do the best that you can every day
i honestly read that as i'm don't worry
about anything it's the beard that
matters more than anything
that's funny bro
here bro
are you from london
uk
i can't wait to visit the uk bro
inshallah
[Music]
about sunisha uh we can't speak on this
we are not qualified to speak on this
yeah we're not qualified and all i'm
going to say is allah knows best
best
we're not qualified um
however i recommend if you want to look
at some i don't know if they've made
video videos on this but check out my
bin farooq
uh
one of the
most
i guess coherent
scholars that i know in the way he
explains and and gives his rulings and
explanations everything is valid so you
can look them up
that's a good question
it depends
it depends on the message
and sometimes like
just the editing of the video
you know like sometimes they'll edit a
video will add like an issue in the
background where like it just sets the
stage for everything
but um if i had to throw someone out
there i would say uh
newman ali khan
he's got some good stuff
but then again like i i don't actively
go out of my way to
to listen to lectures it's it's
sporadically randomly you know what i'm
talking about
hmm
sister samir writes how do you guys seek
knowledge online or books or attending
lectures so what we are currently doing
is we're enrolled in this in this
program in an institution called i3 it's
the letter i
and then the number three three for
sunnah you know and uh we're in this
program believe it or not rami is our
instructor mashallah prof rami uh and he
is a professor in this course um and
what what i3 is it's basically a free
institution where they have multiple
times throughout the week we got people
from the uk in this it's not just people
in north america like us people in
australia people in asia people in
africa people in the west in the
caribbean and what we do is we meet for
one hour a week
and we it's like it's like a legit
course it's not like you just meet with
your boys and you talk about islam no no
it's like there's a there's a curriculum
you know
i'm personally benefiting from this this
is the first step that i took uh
um a couple months in oh no what about
you
it's the same but i was gonna also add i
know fire you do this as well but you
forgot to mention
uh
read books and just articles and things
like that on your own time see videos or
lectures on your own time
but also take like a class because
the class just gives you something where
it makes it consistent no matter what
like every single week
there's going to be the class unless
something pops up unless like you really
can't attend it but it's like you know
you're setting it into your
your pattern of behavior that like okay
every week
i'm studying islam
so then it becomes
a part of you becomes a part of your
life and once it becomes a part of your
life then you start to expand and look
for
you know try to do it in other ways
i didn't know he was a reaver from shia
every time someone says she i think
about like she about it
hmm
and i lost brain cells with that bro
yeah that was
do they have classes for women at i3
institute yeah and not just for women
because because some are mixed classes
but they have they have sister only
classes too
so you know if you can pick out a time i
know where you live i'm not gonna you
know tell everyone but wherever you live
it's definitely not close to north
america time by any means however
there's still multiple times to make
sure that it works with your schedule
and on top of that there's sister only
classes too um with sister only
instructors so it's it's different than
the mixed classes um but unfortunately
we don't have uh brother-only classes i
think that's a little you know
uh
not fair but it is what it is you know
yeah and don't
you know what we're doing i3 but there's
a whole bunch of different teaching
like courses and stuff like that so
don't feel like you have to do i3
look around
ask around see which one is best for you
yeah
uh sister samir asks is it free or
payment yeah i mentioned one more time
bro oh it says it's free
you don't you don't get happy there's
nothing
just for the sake of allah
um
is it possible to join you guys
sometimes like for a conversation yeah
so we're super busy sometimes we barely
even have time and we struggle to make
time to record so we have a patreon and
in the patreon we have a tier where you
can sign up to talk to us and it'll just
be us
so be four of us
the three muslims with you no one else
if you want we can record it and send
you the recording um and there's
different times based on the tier
so yeah link in description
and please don't think that's a plug
because
we barely have enough time for
each other like
just for me on me if i had to have a
conversation
it's
it's it's tough
me you and rami this is a true story
guys by the way we wanted to just talk
amongst us and just like catch up forget
recording bro forget recording just talk
right no setup no nothing audio call i
believe it took over two weeks for us to
just have it and we had it yesterday and
even then we didn't have enough time
yesterday and we were supposed to pick
that up and finish it on sunday bro
wallahi yeah this is a true story guys
so we really don't have enough time as
as we wish we had but if we did we would
love to talk to all you guys in sha
allah in jannah
insha allah and even when we did talk
it it ended up reverting right back to
the whole business t3m so we didn't even
catch up for real for real 100
yes it is
i like it so far
robotics week
all right guys we are going to wrap this
up in five ish minutes
so
last final questions
if you're a youtube member you get first
priority super chats as well and uh
because there's way too many comments
and then once we're done catch us next
friday and if you made it this far
please smash the like button and stay
tuned for
sunday
where we're gonna drop a very special
episode yes you got two episodes this
week hamdullah
i need to give me burgundy soul bro
inshallah bro
inshallah
surah masha allah
[Music]
you funny bro
[Music]
i could be
maybe maybe generations ago i'm bengali
yeah yeah
are you indian you got a little bit of
about indian like indigenous in you you
know who no no i'm native american
aren't they referred to as indian
sometimes bro yeah but he used to be
referring to india the continent how do
you know how do you know
come on bro nah bro like does it do you
see an indian flag bro
all right
brother ahmed are you referring to
indians as native americans or are you
referring to indians
from the continent
or brother armand are you referring to
indian as in both let me know bro
where's the top from bro uh
i want to give a shout out to my parents
my parents bought me a bunch of those
when we went on a trip
to uh saudi and these were in medina not
mecca
yeah medina and they were really good
they were it's from turkey handmade
and male 1 boston
i mean
let's look again i'm gonna get ready i'm
gonna give another mashallah bro
i'm gonna make another answer to this
it's from the same places in in medina
so if you guys ever make a trip to uh
you know i'm not even gonna say that
when you guys make a trip because
there's no if if you guys are capable
you should definitely make a trip to uh
saudi to do amra or hajj
and then uh when you go and find these
uh find some drip make sure you buy it's
very cheap compared to here like if you
want to get one of these stoves here
it's very pricey or even hot but things
are very good prices there and there's a
lot of like merchants so there's no
monopoly kind of like here you know
competitions everywhere so prices are
low
didn't you say you got
uh you got me that black kefia we we go
we go we go keep the prices out of this
okay all right right just so just so it
motivates them to go you know
what is i'm getting
what though bro i don't have a double
bond
i think i think he's talking about you
though no no no bro they think you gotta
throw one
no no this is a there's a hoodie
there's a hoodie this ain't no thug look
it goes up
hold up i don't even see what they said
from morocco
[Music]
we ain't doing fans all right we got
brothers we got family we got sisters
right you guys are family there's no
there's no fans
it's a hoodie
it's a hoodie yes
yes
i mean if this was a though like this
that'd be pretty intricate for though yo
we should make our own dove line yo my
guy comes 53 minutes late into the live
and writes first come on now
come
sounds like a good business to start
here yeah hundred percent yeah inshallah
i have some like crazy is it is it halal
to have like intricate thought designs
again bro we can't speak on photos no so
i can't speak something to look into
something look into it
from algeria
guys before we go let me know where you
guys are from i really want to know
where you're from
uh if it's some crazy countries i'll
definitely pin it up uh on the screen
because some people think that all the
comments we get are on the screen
where in reality it's like one in 500
because there's so many comments bro
i'm liking these artistic
pictures
these avatar pictures that people have
it's giving me ideas
las vegas
afghanistan
is just people just
saying where they're from now
are people just not saying where they're
from
oh mashallah
i love you for the sake of allah
and there's no questions no new york
manchester
london
are you from london
bro the biggest mind bender is uh they
don't call fries fries they call it
chips bro but over here we got chips
like when you got a bag of potato chips
we call that chips i think they call
those crisps bro
yeah someone asked
uh what
do the
british people
like do they have the accent when
they're by themselves or do they speak
english normally and then when they're
around people they have that accent
we got a lot of canadians bro
masha'allah
hey
london
sweden somebody
all right
any questions if not let's uh any more
questions let me know we're going to
stay on this one for two more minutes
legit questions or inquiries and then we
will catch y'all on friday inshaallah
allah same time 11 a.m eastern standard
time
4 p.m
gmt
british time
yes
i just
i'm
want
even gonna say that
for the sake of allah
all right
masha allah
i gotta smash the like button down below
if you made it this far in the stream
and uh
the video that we are tomorrow
go off on that insha allah i'm not gonna
say more than that stay tuned for that
and
have you ever played football
or soccer yeah bro
yes
i'm the law i know you use the ball bro
use the hoop right
basketball
yeah bro i still got a i still got a
ball up on romney your break runs
breaking come through
yeah yes sir
and i got a dunk on on
even more
the time
can any of you back flip
i can do it on trampolines but
i just i never learned to do it on
ground i want to inshallah one day
but on trampolines i could do it for
sure
oh no bro i answer this question so many
times i'ma let you answer it this time
yes
tips on hello dating well there's no
such thing as a lot of dating my friend
check out an episode i made with brother
gabriel romani i believe it's episode
100 or 101 and it was called haram
relationships and all that we go in
depth into this whole thing about dating
and how to navigate insha allah isn't
isn't there allah dating but it's just
not like normal dating it's just adding
that little label on to it
no you're getting to know you're getting
to know the individual but like what the
following that's not dating i highly
recommend they they check that out halal
dating is basically when they say okay
we're still together but we won't do
anything that there's none of that oh no
no no no yeah that's not
that is not so
okay i came at the end of the stream uh
three more questions about how did you
find the j.p mohammed job discussion
well we made a reaction
so i haven't even watched the entire
thing yet but 100 like from what i've
seen amazing
amazing
my takeaway is that it's better that we
burn bridges
with people and
truly
at least get the narrative out of their
mind that muslims are this that and the
other instead of just getting a shahadah
every single time we interact with them
i'm not saying it's not important to to
guide people into islam but what's most
important sometimes now all the time
today is just getting this twisted
version of islam and muslims out of
their head and just show them that we're
good people we're friendly people
live by example akhlaq so on and so
forth
how does that burn a breeze though
how's that burning bridge though
how does one burn the bridge
what you just said you said sometimes
it's better to burn a bridge
no build a bridge carried on you said
burn the bridge bro my bad bro i might
build a bridge
it's never good to burn bridges bro
yeah yeah
okay this one second last question i
don't know what about you tips for
handling confrontation
experience them more often
try to put your emotions aside try to
see it from a more logical
more rational perspective the more you
experience them
and don't run away from them or don't
close off
and just shut up completely
you start to be able to process them and
actually you know
not maybe get flustered or nervous or
you know just caught up to where you
can't see nothing
it's just again it's just a matter of
like going through them
you know but it's
takes a little bit i will say that takes
a little bit
yeah and bro i can't believe i said burn
bridges bro i meant to say build bridges
that's funny i know brah that's why i i
like said it there so no i'm still i'm
seeing because other people are
commenting that too yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i guess one last question
one last question and then we're out of
this all right we already have the
one-hour mark allah mubarak
reminded guys jamaa is obligatory for
men
all right i don't know what you guys
think juma's not obligatory or i don't i
can't have time i have this i have the
dunya well just just go to jamaa come on
you know you got to do it if you still
have that voice telling you to go your
fiddler is not corrupt just go make it
happen insha allah ah shower me coastal
you know clean yourself do we do nicely
don't trim your nails look all fresh
um
and then just go to jummah inshallah
because who knows man
with all the lockdowns and everything
what if we go to lockdown and measure
mushroom for like another six months we
still got time so while you still got
time to take action inshallah
with that being said last question bro
last question we got
was okay there's not really a question
but apus didn't like the interview
uh with jp because he doesn't want
bridges built
i guess so bro allahu allah
yeah all right with that being said i
don't know bro do your thing
i wasn't even gonna say that
what you're gonna
give a little something different bro
give them something different then bro
something different
the brothers and sisters
if you watch the entire thing
may allah bless you
if
you just came at the end
may allah bless you as well but what
what the hell are you doing coming at
the end you got to come on time
always got to be punctual got gotta be
on time
with that being said we love you all for
the sake of allah and
yes i still do as [ __ ] everyone else
it's focus attention but with that being
said
my